is there a specific structure you use in
your screenplays yeah I mean there's a
there's a you know I generally you know
defer to the classic storytelling
structure which is which is the three
act the three act structure the the the
different that likes of a series of
movements across across the whole script
I break it down into into three acts
four quarters twelve twelve sequences
yeah I mean III honestly any time I try
to mix it up a little bit less but
there's a big believer in drawing inside
the lines and then messing it up you
know but at least knowing that you've
got your framework the way the way the
way that that these story most stories
are told best and most effectively and
then you can kind of mess it up and
smudge it up and you know kind of put
your stamp on it you know and all of
that every I'm not such a big believer
that that what's supposed to happen on
page 60 happens exactly on page 60 well
if it's page 58 or 63 or if it based
upon the length you to script 42 as long
as the movements or the proportion of
your story is right the the the the
movements you know kind of are kind of
the the kind of traditional store in a
traditional classic storytelling because
traditional always sounds like it's you
know you're just in a box that's that to
me is important but I'm a big believer
in structure I believe you get really
found out that but why your story isn't
working when you kind of when you kind
of don't follow some kind of structure
you know some kind of classic will be
moving the storytelling structure so
going back to when you were at the
writers boot camp how would you know a
story was great but it just needed to
have more structure and fused in it well
sometimes I I believe you can structure
any story you have to have enough of a
story you have to have enough of an of
an enough of a kind of a of a way to
expand that story into a full movie you
know sometimes you watch a movie you got
nothing happened in that movie or it was
what a bunch of nothing you know
whatever it was really because there may
not have been enough story sometimes my
very first screenplay I I had three
different ideas for scripts and I ended
up putting all three together and I
found my story individually each story
may not have been
somehow or other all three of those
ideas together just sort of work fit
like this puzzle and I was able to you
know to create this script so there's
that you know it's kind of is there's
that approach to it but it you know
basically you know a good story when you
hear or do you know the beginnings of a
good story a story that has potential or
an interesting character or a kind of a
lot of stories are just set up it's like
well ba bla bla bla bla bla bla well
that's great but like what happens then
because that's only taking me through
the first act and the second act is
always the most difficult act if you
don't know where you're going and most
anybody can write the first act of a
script but it's where it goes from there
that that's tricky so sometimes an idea
may be just all set up and there's not
much beyond that but if you take another
idea and pare it and another idea and
bring it in and kind of layer it then
you may have more of that story it's
about finding the story you can look
like I said you can structure anything
you can create a structure as long as
there's enough story and finding that
story you know which is the challenge
you